[Musique]
je suis chaud chaud chaud
ce soir je suis qu'à moi toujours je
suis un peu embêté quoi besoin je suis
un peu
[Musique]
apple est tombé
ap les bébés
ses proches
c'est propre on est propre le mec
rien de mieux très très bon c'est en
fait y'a rien de moins soit rien de
mieux en ce moment je voulais y je vous
le dit tiens il dort encore médecins
dogba amiens n'a pas des pastilles sais
pas il a repas
j'ai l'impression de planer regarder
dans le blanc des yeux bruns fait
ap pompiers
c'est parti
n'est-il pas départi quelle partie kane
le médecin
e
puis chaud chaud chaud
ayant entouré pas un truc à ça sur le
bout des cinq cents 500 le goût et les
cinq sens ça sent le brûlé après les
mauvais ça sent le brûlé 500 ça sent le
brûlé sa 80e année ça ça ça sent le
bonnet ça ça ça sent le bois laisse à
elle a passé un mystérieux là dedans
j'ai l'impression de planer
je suis un peu
je suis enfin je suis enfin je suis en
paix
ça
je
pas mal
très propre by bâton
à l'heure du midi lui
[Musique]
vu
je
[Musique]
il
ce
oh
[Musique]
la changer
le cas vous avez eu plus empreinte
[Musique]
lève à dépasser son maître
oui elle
[Musique]
bah ma chérie
le jazz a mis plus en prada aux eaux
à 5-1 à l'émission forgé merci mon
général ça se passe et dans est arrivée
elle doit faire ça vous avez dormi un
peu vous cette reprise toiture est avec
moi toute la journée quand que s il y en
a qui se réveille avec moi je refais des
gros bisous les chéris d'en avoir on va
faire la lame le morning de virgin radio
surtout après une petite écharpe
machinerie non merci quand même parce
qu'à lyon
[Musique]
les produits
si vous voulez bon là je serai
[Musique]
m
c'est camille sée baba camille et baba
il s'en souviendra
baba
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis gérer ni de
chartes nous sommes aujourd'hui le
vendredi 14 octobre je suis comme un ouf
le fait de présenter d'ouvrir cette
émission de malade mental avec bike amis
je voudrais dire une seule chose
bonjour alors mes chéris comment ça va
et toi je suis content d'y aller mollo
studio 1 t'as vu ça c'est la première
émission ses compétences nous annonce
quelques-unes gamme c'est vachement bien
c'est ça le siège soit donnée c'est dans
cette suite c'est un jeu tu veux un
dossier je suis rien on a tout mis sur
la déco des frères alors c'est très bien
hu est très beau mais ba ba tu vas pas
tenir aussi voir messi frère tu peux pas
te vois il ya un gars tu veux lui parler
il a 100 m libre en fait pas une piscine
ici ça met une balle
par contre il ya des mof sur la tête
derrière les meufs on dirait du saint
moret même jour à jérémy qu'avec du
caveau 39,16 a bailar au téléphone avec
nous salut je suis là nous pensons
qu'une seule et même personne
non mais franchement tu sais on commence
à manger en même temps quel âge j'ai 35
ans ça va super ça fait super plaisir de
vous avoir tous les deux tout ça déchire
tu fais quoi dans la vie
dans l'automobile
non qu'elle marc vazy dit nous on peut
nous dire ça va faire plaisir à jean luc
lemoine si nous revient ce matin il ya
le patron de la radio dans un coin il ya
le producteur de l'autre on peut dire
toutes les marques
le patron de la rassure bien sûr vous le
connaissez bien sûr un brushing et et
sono
fredo ce qui m'inquiète c'est vu sa tête
on dirait c'est lui qui fait les 35
heures je suis par contre dans le cas
parce qu'on en direct en fait aussi sur
celle exactement sur s'éviter sur virgin
est alors allé voir la tête de série en
vrai bien bah ouais alors bon ça c'est
davantage du pakistan ah non mais là le
pakistanais a une peau in a move et la
batterie très bien qu'on a des petits
ions lemoine et web et bien sûr mais ça
fait partie du jour ne peut pas arriver
trop voilà être moi là il ferait frais
fera bientôt cha cha doo frais tout a
commencé hier à 14h tu es comment là en
vrai franchement je suis bien c'est bien
ça j'ai envie d'en découdre non parce
que c'est une belle antenne virgin radio
le virgin tonique c'est une super
émission c'est vraiment quelque chose
que j'ai dans le coeur quoi j'irai
peut-être était toujours là moi j'irai
me suis très content de t'avoir c'est
que ces démissions de camille donc c'est
camille patron moi je suis là bien sûr
en soutien tant qu'invité voilà si tu as
besoin vraiment d'un soutien des
animations tunisie sera pas moi je crois
tu n'auras pas besoin mais je suis là en
soutien moral
non non non non on fait toutes les
missions avec cyril il ya aussi bien sûr
ma petite loge m'amuse indjai dans
l'intrus à l'ugap au lido standard on
fiche là haut la barre temps d'arrêt
délicat de juger mon sens une meilleure
liaison avec les gars qu'on envoie sur
la lune que avec pauline qui avot à deux
mètres cinquante au standard et la meuf
allez allez ya juste une vitre mais une
vie du genre de la poste lassé c'est les
soldes on dirait qu'on a eu on va au
guichet mon cas on soit qu'au lycée
maucourant ouais j'ai reçu ça y est
jérémy je voudrais dire mon chéri tu vas
aller au travail la provençale patron
jean-pierre toyota qui est vraiment un
pote ça qu il est cool il est cool c'est
que il a des problèmes avec guy nissan
arrête tes conneries des fois il ya des
nouvelles jean-pierre des ou non mais
juge encore hyundai franchement j'ai eu
et j'ai eu didier mitsubishi et ses
ventes après vu plein de trucs se dit
déjà
il va y avoir des cadeaux magnifique
pour vous quel est le cadeau qu'on gagne
avec le jeu des 35 secondes tuba les 35
heures cyril tout au long de l'émission
on passera des gens on leur posera des
questions rafale pendant 35 secondes
si quelqu'un pièces cette bonne réponse
en 35 secondes peut-être toi jérémy il
repart les coûts du bureau séjour à
punta cana jours à punta cana
les gens appellent peu dominique
[Musique]
ça ce sera le jeu des 35 secondes jérémy
là tu sais quoi tu démarres cette
émission tu restes avec nous dans deux
minutes à peine tu sera le premier à
essayer si dès le premier tu arrives à
faire cette bonne réponse séjour à punta
cana pour toi d'accord offrir des
macbook air ça veut dire dernier
téléphone de chapeau
le téléphone ordinateur sur téléphone on
a des smartphones on a des six-jours mmv
pour 4 personnes partout en france cyril
chinois de mmv résidence de vacances
plus d'accord comme le vvf parce que je
pense village vacances familles et oui
c'était un peu au dessous et les ipad
mini à ces bosses sais pas qui paie tous
ces cadeaux mais ont ils fait rentrer de
l'oseille le cam iko
heureusement qu'il est là dans le groupe
lagardère
votre radio faut bien connu un qui fasse
rentrer de l'oseille dans ce bourg en
gironde à mettre la clé sous la porte et
découvre par voulait pas un cyril te
perdre c'est moi c'est huit ans mais ça
veut dire virgin radio ils perdent
camille combal mon frère ça veut dire
c'est tout le groupe lagardère ils sont
les gars s'est passé les partis sur une
autre radio une petite ovation pour le
pauvre y aura sera aussi on paye plus
personne même elkabbach le pauvre jean
pierre
et on doit le payer en livre pas ses
bonnes je m'en allais gameiro ménez
jusqu'à 10h tiendra fin du blind test en
faire plein de trucs soit on va
s'éclater à plein de gens qui veulent te
parle aux 39 16 et dans un instant vous
pouvez faire des tu préfères à cyril
j'adore on va demander tu préfères de
proposition à chaque fois il lui répond
alors le dernier qui ma faim tu préfères
c'est matthieu delormeau et alors j'ai
dit je comprends rien je préfères tu
rentres chez toi en direction des rejets
dans le disait en direct sur ces 8
on voit tout les caméras ne voyais plus
cyril c'est kim kardashian mais ça veut
dire que j'espère juste que je n'aurais
pas la même mésaventure et puis
franchement j'ai des bracelets à 5 euros
les 4 g pour mieux vous faites pas chier
pour ça énorme juste mon camille pendant
qu'on va écouter de la musique donc nous
là on sera là en ambiance à mais nous on
est mort on écoute la musique parce
qu'il ya de la musique sur ces vitaux
s'il ya de la musique on est là sur ces
8 vous pouvez sûr vous serez avec nous
dans les coulisses ok évidemment vous
verrez si sir est la vrai bon la forme
on va pourtant là oui j'ai envie de dire
santé à la santé des mousquetaires est
avec nous je des 35 secondes avec toi
dans un instant tu seras le premier et
toute la matinée le jeu des 35 secondes
et tout de suite
est ce que tu aimes bernichan soccer
c'est toi qui restaient dans le coup la
légende mais j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'aime bien ce qu'ils font je trouve
qu'ils se soient un petit peu perdu son
dernier album mois sera peut être le
premier pas car ils sont sur la pente
savonneuse pas d'accord 608 c'est parti
c'est le grito dit que jusqu'à 10 heures
émission exceptionnelle avec cyril
hanouna qui est avec nous et qui bat son
record avec tout ce matin 35 heures
voilà
direct pour voir ma gueule pendant 35
ans je peux dire qu'après il traça on va
calculer combien il reste à cyril
revient dans son arrêt il paraît les
gardes sans les collines c'est un scoop
ça fait combien de temps que sur
l'antenne la base à 16 heures 16 heures
il paraît qu arthur a regardé 15h55 de
l'émission soit à peine de ma mère c'est
fermé c'est simple pas croire toutes les
conneries je revois tes américain de
soutien j'utilise mon coeur donc les
pizzas ou c'est parti c'est sur virgin
soyez les bienvenus sur virgin radio
mon frérot cyril hanouna qui va passer
l'émission avec nous c'est camille
combal et baba dans le dire gym tonic ce
matin ça va proto jeu content d'être là
franchement ils voudraient embrasser
tous les auditeurs de virgin radio est
également tous les auditeurs de radio
classique de chant de france alors vous
savez que alors j'ai de radio que je
kiffe moi c'est bien jean adoue quand
même parce que je écoute énormément et
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup en
rotation beaucoup par rotation va pas se
mentir
la deuxième personne en rotation voilà
cette radio après quelques au chanteur
qu'il y ait des chanteurs après il ya
camille combal aprilia les chanteurs et
j'adore champ de france j'aime aussi non
mais c'est vrai ce que vous êtes bon par
exemple en chanson française oui tu veux
conteste dans un instant vas-y et grand
plaisir on peut faire un blind test va
nous falloir de mieux préparer la can
real qu'à 17 ans au fort qui donnait
michel c sans déconner on peut voir le
run away le rien mais qui fait l'affront
de lumière cette approche de l'histoire
qui a plus vrai ou faux quoi ta cage
j'ai 21 ans 21 ans sur ma bon et je vais
dans la vie des marges et les courges et
je fais une fac de droit côté non la
raison continuer là-dessus je te devais
te dire fais gaffe quand même à la radio
aussi ça va ça vient
la peña qui s'est mangé la porte mais je
te le dis et tu veux faire quoi dans le
droit non sérieusement je fais de la
radio et à l'avenir je le sens en
question faire réalisateur ware et
animations un peu tout je veux tout
faire votre bouffe et à bouffer le sang
lui c'est quoi son prénom
robin robin j'aime pas j'aime bien le
gars j'aime bien le gars sur le web je
sens que lui alors là les peu de dire
oui tu es malade trois jours à venir
c'est le robin tomic le ghana le badge
passe plus mais camille combal il te
mets dans dernier d'histoire vous passez
à côté de robespierre et danton et
révolutionnaire la radio balances tout
sur son chemin
c'est bien c'est qui rougit pas sur la
vérité est sympa mais tu as une tête de
tarbes à la place merci mais je t'aime
bien serrés ces séries qui s'est
rarement trompé à ce qu'on appelle le
radar attarde
c'est vrai dans les ailes nous tu aimes
bien que tu veux faire quoi
quant aux radios et télés télénantes
n'ont pas tous les noms n'ont même pas
comment je suis à l'aise la face à la
caméra je pense que je vais rester
détrompe toi tu es très à l'aise non
mais je ne ressemble à m pokora et ils
étaient dans les link up
je connais pas tu croit en son étoile
je connais même pas les dingle il a 21
ans je veux c'est trouver non mettant
mes repas c'est est là pour l'instant en
train de chercher du michel sardou quoi
c'est toujours mpokora ses meilleures
audiences
ce matin les radios sont musicalement ce
sera ce sera une ambiance un se bat à
est-ce qu on reprendrait pas jérémy pour
le jeu des 35 secondes
j'irai me tais tu recommences à quelle
heure de travail attaqué poche commence
à 8h tu travailles vachement tôt et
ouais c'est pourtant prendre avec
camille sée près d'accord en fait tu
t'en fous complètement du travail c'est
nous qui tape long c'est toi qui appelle
s'offrait de virgin radio frais de
virgin moi parce que c'est un coup comme
ça a été le coup de téléphone comme ça
que j'ai un portable savoir un appel à
la fin du mois ne pas trop marché des
banques
jérémy on va inaugurer avec toi et on
sera peut-être gagner dès à présent là
tout de suite le jeu qui va te permettre
de partir des propres août à cannes
puisque syrie est en train de battre un
record exceptionnel jamais fait sur la
télé en france 35 heures d'antenne il
tient bien le coup il m'impressionne
c'est quoi elle récupérer mais carbo pas
du tout il en pleine patate francs
patate seconde chance la pomme de terre
aux maximum de questions 35 secondes le
premier de la matinée n'importe quelle
heure on va passer plein de monde qui
obtiendra cette bonne réponse en 35
secondes par rapport à cannes a attaqué
et les prix nobel on a eu punta onu
kanaan et les deux tout va bien on a
laissé jouer les magnifiques tous frais
payés
jérémy est ce que tu te sens prêt j'ai
la pression du coup on compte les points
ma petite lors du cru les points
attention elle a même pas un papier
c'est là ils sont venus pour rien faire
qui fera attention bossé toute l'année
il a arraché à l'olive attention et bien
sûr et j'oublie même de vous dire
excusez moi quand même y avons rendez
vous dans votre loyer est à gagner dans
un instant même en direct à la télé tout
on continue de vous faire plaisir six
ans va 7h28 à 22h20 loyers aux
attentions 35 secondes top chrono quel
numéro zinedine zidane porté sur son
maillot quand il joue au real
le lisais rap de victor hugo quel est le
prénom de la mère de cosette rachida
l'info la jolie fergie était de la
chanteuse les baby black eyed peas black
eyed peas
quelle ville de belgique est aussi
appelée la venise du nord viennent ces
deux journées la charia de quelques
clubs de football de ligue 1 jean michel
aulas et il le président guingamp de
combien pour dire qu'aucun des -40
arrêté du 10 au carré - sentais mal j ai
pas exactement ça fait sens en moins 40
égale 60 un pain c'est la bonne réponse
ça veut dire que celle aurait eu
quelques bonnes réponses et on a eu zéro
mon poteau alors le séjour à punta cana
n'est pas pour toi mais par contre on a
notre ville cepoun taratra c'est la
ville de laon était là avec nous depuis
six ans a démarré cette émission un
cadeau merci mon poteau mais quoi des
cadeaux ce à quoi on pourrait devrait à
quoi on passe du côté des radios qui ont
tant fait un truc le sol en en fait moi
j'ai rien
à des téléphones oui j'ai envie de dire
cocorico elle fait le tour des radios
vous payer leur loyer dans deux secondes
et les perdants partent avec un
smartphone chez nous c'est pas mal c'est
bon sens on va m'en rappelle à l'époque
quand j'étais à la radio le perdant sur
la tête de ma mère il nous donnait de
losail les gars on les appelait ouais
euh
kevin dis moi ça fait deux semaines que
tu as perdu au journal je suis un trio
nicolas il avait bien sûr y aller je me
dis qu il t'a préparé être là où on va
ça fait tellement longtemps qu'il est là
c'est vrai il pas que cela tenait
maintenant des gens mais bien plus sur
la vie de ma mère il sera plus dur que
philippe bouvard intervient six ans le
gars était là il n'y avait même pas
citée par virgin la radio la merced
d'eux mêmes par mon frère elle
s'applique à pirater
on aura joséphine au bord ni qui va et a
préparé une belle surprise tu te
rappelles de fa si la chanter cusack
j'adorais on va le refaire ce matin à
poser des questions faciles à chanter et
cyril vous permettra peut-être de
repartir avec un macbook air sauvage
mais pour les gens ça c'est pour celui
qui a les seins celui qui permettra au
barca avec un voyage au bout de la terre
ou ta merde c'est pas bon on prend la
mer ils sont bas dir est mais tu restes
avec nous ce n'est qu'à leur normalement
jetés stx elle a normalement il ya déjà
eu la pub on est des gens loyer est
d'accord le moment on est encore avec
jérémy d'accord il va falloir compter
selon gm ne veut pas jouer les oiseaux
toujours d'accord j'ai la vie je
t'embrasse je vous fais très très gros
bisou pour avéré pour les 35 heures et
camille se déchire tout cette émission
mon poteau et alors vous l'avez compris
6h10 heure peut-être jusqu'à midi 1 ce
matin le virgin tonique à offrir mais
j'ai d'autres émissions nous on te
lâchera quand on te lâchera mgmt qui te
voilà ce qu'on va écouter dans un
instant sur virgin reste avec tout le
poids que vous aimez si c'est bien mes
frères c'est pas rien après chercher du
michel sardou pour toi mais pas de
michèle sabban pour qui aime et fais moi
blanc tests avec des ces fonds mais je
n'ai pas d'autre nous amener à mais je
sais pas moi georges les mecs
j'aurais pokora soprano tapas 6 mai -
mines de michel sardou
nous sommes à j d'ordonnancement
bougeait pas bon à la banque postale ils
ont étudié votre tendance à garder votre
chère vieille voiture à la banque
postale ils ont aussi étudié qu'elle
vous coûte quand même plus cher que vous
ne l'imaginez 1 parce qu'elle demande
beaucoup d'entretien c'était chez une
vieille voiture heureusement à la banque
postale quand ils étudient ils agissent
alors jusqu'au 5 novembre 2016 profiter
de leur bateau sur le prêt personnel
auto est en route pour financer votre
nouvelle voiture
c'est ça l'énergie citoyenne renseigner
loviton bureaux de poste ou 38,39
service 15 centimes d'euro la minute
plus prix de l'appel la banque postale
banques et citoyenne
après acceptation de votre dossier par
la banque postale financement vous
disposez d'un délai de rétractation la
banque postale intermédiaire de crédit
du prêteur skalli et baba vous payez sur
virgin radio 1 bonjour à tous ce petit
point trafic avec une panne à signaler
sur l'a6b vers la province entre a
recueilli cheville à camion est aussi à
l'arrêt sur l'a6 vers paris au niveau de
chilly-mazarin a partout ailleurs c'est
encore fluide ce matin à 6 heures 22
pour ce qui est de la météo ça va être
grisaille et pluie toute la journée sur
l'île de france 10 degrés ce matin à
melun à versailles on à paris pas plus
de 15 degrés pour cet après midi et puis
ce week-end ça va être un mélange de
nuages et soleil sur toute la région
parisienne
3 5 un vent de gaieté souffle sur la
vallée village un village à ciel ouvert
une escapade à deux pas de paris où tout
est conçu pour vous rendre heureux
vous y retrouverez les plus grandes
marques de mode avec des réductions à
donner le vertige
laissez vous porter sans attendre un
large choix sur les collections
précédentes dans plus de 110 boutiques
accès facile par autoroute a4 rer a
station val d'europe ou navette de paris
sept jours sur sept
destination la vallée village jacques
duhault retenir de la tournée de
synapses salue ses six nations en
novembre
retrouvez synap sont dans les meilleures
salles prêtées vous plus duo électro le
plus fédérateur du moment en fera
notamment le 3 novembre à la salle
pleyel à paris dans toute la france pour
une tournée exceptionnelle
[Musique]
alors
synapse temps en tournée avec virgin
radio la radio est plus beaux concerts
pyatt et par sms avec des milliers de
connecter envoyé libre suivi du numéro
de votre département pour 60 de 333
partenaires naïve new beaters
cellulite on est les meilleurs beat vous
les avez découverts sur virgin radio
retrouvez le groupe de pop le plus chez
look et de france à la cigale à paris le
20 octobre devant toute la france
pourrait tourner à la folie
cliquez vous maintenant sur virgin du
point fr
colas sa tournée d'une rive new beaters
les pièces d or famille est là bas vous
paye peut travailler sur virgin radio à
rooney de retour sur virgin radio en
direct bien sûr vous le savez merci de
nous suivre si nombreux chaque matin et
pour cette matinale exceptionnel quand
même on est à la radio avec mon petit
cyril hanouna cayla qui bat le record à
nos côtés et puis en même temps en
direct sur ces 8 vous pouvez nous suivre
à la télé on a mis un micro 6,6 et il
micro sabotage ils veulent plus voir mes
amis le gilet de gilles verdez où tu
dois ya un micro dirait un gamin de
quitter united
[Musique]
il est beaucoup trop long qui l'arrêté
qui faisait ou flex united sait trop
bien car ici j'adore
ils ont fait à laleu l'oiseau et
l'enfant non plus au départ ce qui fait
pas les oiseaux
ce qui fait que les nombreux mensonges
et rtt méfiant je t'aime idole for a day
qui demande un truc ça parle d'un
portage c'est que c'est important pour
les gens il faudrait qu'on leur payer
leur loyer c'est parce qu'il va attaquer
leur sens vraiment cette affaire non non
c'est à 6h20 7h dans la 5 millions $
alors je vais bien et la tension
commence à dépasser 2 5 minutes à chaque
fois on donne le voyez en juillet
maintenant c'est toi qui va l'offrir
c'est très simple vous vous inscrivez et
ça c'est important
ce matin encore quatre tirages au sort
là c'est votre rendez-vous compter
dessus y'a pas de raison que ça s'arrête
ce matin loyau 7 12 13 par sms voilà
comment vous inscrire vous laissez bien
votre numéro de téléphone
on vous rappelle en direct usa s'est
fait tirer 3 qui va le faire on demande
aux gens qu'elle est la seule radio qui
paye le loyer y a pas de piège on est
les seuls à y a pas de piège ce rôle-là
ballon s'ils répondent virgin radio
c'est gagné pour eux aussi répondre sans
de france où vous envoient eux marc
lavoine chez vous il a droit
alors on y va on y va donc on n'a pas vu
une personne personne s'inscrit
c'est la troisième seulement en appelant
masqué soient décrochés bien sûr merci
lors je décroche très rarement masqué
moi c'est souvent la compagnie créole tu
m'appelles si déçu que ça décroche pas
oui moi aussi si on appelait khaled
non c'est pas vrai il y voit bien la
partie il est avec aïcha non c'est vrai
est khaled il a pas répondu at dans sa
douche
bah ouais je me laisse à 6h26 tu es dans
ta douche bas c'est à cause de nous
aussi on avait six minutes de retard bah
les amis je suis désolé pour khaled et
pour vous tous qui m'écoutait
malheureusement il va falloir vous
réinscrire les amis pour le tirage de
cette oeuvre on n'a pas le droit de vous
rappeler et on va offrir donc le premier
loyer j'espère hier ce sera à 7h20 je
suis un peu déçu un peu déçu pour rooney
ouais moi aussi je suis sûr puis ça
décroche très souvent je tape ne porte
pas à l'oeil en hauteur
c'est du moins comme ça je vais ça va
être aussi simple que ça je vais roulé
ma bosse seul tu sais moi aussi j'ai des
projets moi aussi j'ai des gens qui
m'appellent je ne suis pas seul au monde
non mais je te le dis on devait faire un
tu préfères avec toi cyril sa branche on
râle est c'est fini on le roule
entendable chypre japon n'a pas le droit
de rappeler d'art et au mobilier direct
us elles sont assez stricts écoute
j'espère que khaled ne verra pas de
l'appeler en fait ça c'est le pire
le g20 n'est pas d'infos à la sté khaled
et puis vous vous pouvez rejouer à 720
dans une heure loyau 7 12 13 par sms
cyril gtepro bien facile à chanter n'est
pas arrivé on a un blind test cet humour
sur le cheveu attention il en train de
se préparer spécial variété française on
va s'affronter mais avant je voulais te
faire des tu préfères ahmadi et surtout
vous les amis appelé souhaiter bonne
chance à cyril pour les 35 heures ça se
passe où 39,16 vous le savez vous passez
sur l'antenne
et vous pouvez aussi faire des tu
préfères à cyril équipe ouais lancé j'en
ai aussi barascud coup roulé tout ce que
vous les faites des tu préfères et on
prend le bras du monde au téléphone
clément au quai seynois cyril et face à
toi et écoutant d'encenser manif que
répond sérieusement est-ce que tu
préfères mais pour toutes les émissions
pour toute ta vie
à voir la tête de sophie marceau et le
corps de guy roux ou alors le corps de
sophie marceau et la tête de guy roux
alors voilà déjà
la question se pose pas puisque j'ai
déjà le code donc aux claviers sort la
tête de l'eau à la limite je franchement
ça ne pourrait que gradés la personne la
personne sera engagée en fait je garde
le rocco les ja existants et je rajoute
la tête de sophie marceau
voilà avons pas très bien ça paraît le
seul truc que j'aime beaucoup mais je ne
veux rien avoir à faire avec cyril
lignac
je ne mange pas de ce piment le voit la
mer ça j'aime beaucoup la personne et je
respecte
l'or est ce que tu veux faire un tu
préfères way
ah si tu préfères avis avoir une haleine
de chacal ou avis et geneviève de
fontenay qui travaillent le matin on
aimerait dire franchement alors je veux
dire avant moi je préfère que ce soit à
vis jeunes via de fond et qui me
réveille le matin mais tu t'endors avec
le soir du coup ouais mais frère on l'a
fait que copier à laquelle ses amis sur
une personne voilà d'un certain âge on
la respecte
elle dort à la maison si elle veut
vendre quatre dans le frigo fait ce
qu'elle veut mais bon tranquille ici moi
non mais elle est très gentille l
adorable femme bien très bien ça donne
ça c'est plutôt posé sur du gdir mebazaa
a salué l' ça comme si ma chérie d'être
là elle est belle ça va non ça fait
franchement je me sens bien dans ses 35
ans c'est quoi
je me demande si je veux pas le faire
tous les jours c'est ma vie c'est pas ça
alors elsa tu fais quoi dans la vie dans
laquelle on va essayer de trouver une
parade à la corde on l'attend d'accord
pas très bon bnp paribas j'aime bien et
j'aime bien la bnp paribas ils sont
sérieux alors c'est la banque de mon
père c'est la banque de mon père la
barbe et paribas ben tu vois c'est tout
ce que vous voulez savoir
merci
je suis sympa tout avoir je voulais me
faire à lui préfère c'est quoi ma chérie
oui mon petit tu préfères tu le roules
tu te le mets sur l'oreille dans le
respect ou les tensions dans l'axé bien
sûr l'oreille que tu te lemay et uvale
de le dire à syrie dans un instant vous
aussi faites des tu préfères à cyril on
est là jusqu'à 10 heures si on était
également en direct sur ces 8 et pour le
moment c'est les infos petit point sur
les infos avec tous nos journalistes
partout en france
julien doré le lac st cyr et ils adorent
ils écoutent que ça on le doit bien
dorées l'accès tout un programme
la preuve qu'il faut s'y préparer
le bol des méchancetés bon c'est pas un
bol avec tous les chroniqueurs de tmp un
autre bol avec ou des gentillesses ou
d'aimer chanter et selon ce que tu dis
que tu tiens par exemple valérie bénaïm
gentillesse lundis gentillesse mais
ensuite les choses peuvent encore
changer
c'est à quelle heure les enfants passer
maintenant martine aubry est important
pour moi j'ai besoin de me documenter
également c'est tous et je vis avec mon
temps j'ai besoin d'une fenêtre ouverte
sur le monde ses parties ils ont mis
leur plus belle écharpe ces deux
journalistes on les écoute on y va c'est
parti
[Musique]
et les infos partout en france et avec
mon petit guillaume la riche comment ça
va guillon ça te fait plaisir de revoir
syrie cyril ça fait plaisir en assemblée
quelques années n'a pas changé non plus
tous les deux à six heures du matin
vraiment a le teint superbe un petit 1
allez ça te va très bien merci
face à la maison ce soir lui avec
geneviève la météo avec toujours quatre
départements en alerte
innovation orange sur l'aude l'aveyron
le gard et une alerte rouge sur le
département de l'hérault avec quelques
éclaircies sur la façade atlantique
aujourd'hui de la pluie et des nuages
partout ailleurs au lendemain du débat
télévisé sur tf1 entre les sept
candidats à la primaire de la droite
pour la présidentielle française alain
juppé est donné gagnant d'après une
étude publiée à après la fin de
l'émission
le maire de bordeaux juste devant
nicolas sarkozy et bruno le maire
prochain débat le 3 novembre
un proviseur et son adjointe violemment
agressé hier matin dans un lycée
professionnel du 93 l'élève de seconde
âgé de 15 ans qui les a frappé au visage
n'a pas encore été interpellé après
avoir été interrompu hier les cours
reprennent ce matin au lycée l'ena de
saint-denis et kim kardashian partie
civile dans l'enquêté sur son vol de
neuf millions d'euros de bijoux survenue
voilà bientôt deux semaines à paris à la
bimbo star de 35 ans va également
déposer plainte pour violation de sa vie
privée contre l'auteur et les diffuseurs
d'une vidéo réalisée lorsque les
policiers procéder aux premiers crus
constatations dans l'hôtel particulier
où a eu lieu l'agression inauguré mardi
par la ministre de la santé marisol
touraine la première salle de
consommation de drogue en france ouvre
aujourd'hui ce local de plus de 400
mètres carrés situé près de la gare du
nord à paris
les toxicomanes vont pouvoir accéder
sept jours sur sept dans cette salle de
shoot financés par la sécurité sociale
le coup d'envoi de la 9e journée de
ligue 1 de football avec toulouse monaco
ce soir 19h nice lyon à 20h45 le paris
saint germain jouera pour sa part demain
à partir de 17 heures match à nancy à
les nouveaux albums de la semaine avec
celui de julien doré vous ne manquerez
pas non plus la compil vers d'une radio
les crocs starter alors groupe la
playlist électro de virgin radio avec
l'asie et meneur môme jonas blue et
plein d'autres artistes encore et puis
vers gin-tonic avec le son et l'image ce
matin
une matinale à la fois sur verte une
radio et sur ses 8 pour une spéciale des
deux complices de touche pas à mon poste
camille combal et cyril hanouna cyril
qui a débuté hier à 14 heures un
marathon télévisuel pour le coup avec
pour objectif d'assurer 35 heures de
direct stop c'est bien parti en tout cas
pour battre ce record est pour ça cyril
va devoir tenir jusqu'à ce soir 23h au
moins est peut-être plus qui sait pour
battre encore plus soit encore à 2h du
mat 2h du mat les scuds moi j'ai fait
des mauvais calcul car il est moins
c'est ça
jamy et baba
bon c'est beau hein alors on a besoin
d'avancer toile fameux camille alors
c'est toi ça donne à dans tout le monde
sait ça toute la france bruisse combat
cerveau cyril il tient le coup a
vraiment 35 heures il a commencé
l'antenne à 14 heures hier sur sa vie
tournait d'ailleurs toujours en direct
un sursis mais il pouvait aller voir
vous découvrez notre nouveau studio
radio comme notre producteur ce matin
qui nous découvrent aussi assez beau
parce que c'est moi qui ai fait des
travaux nous voilà à quoi bon plan voir
le petit placoplâtre aux murs et donc
c'est moi le béa très ce que tu voulais
pas ça donne ceci fait son petit effet
je te lis soyez les bienvenus en tout
cas on est très très très heureux d'être
là en direct l'émission très
particulière mais on sera là entre 6h et
10h comme on l'est tous les matins avec
vous c'est toujours le même numéro c'est
le 39 16 pour nous jouons n'hésitez pas
cette émission c'est avant tout la vôtre
on va faire un blind test avec cyril
vous pouvez nous parler elle inquiète
avec nous déjà ou 39,16 votre loyer vous
le savez c'est toutes les heures des
macbook air à vous offrir et des séjours
à punta cana n'importe quel moment vous
m'appelez 39 16 ans et le jeu des 35
secondes le premier qui donne cette
bonne réponse
il repart avec un séjour tous frais
payés mais un séjour de fou on va base
d'hôtel de dengue et tout un tas
faisait-on galère et une tante du cheval
à bas je sais c'est vraiment ça c'est
des cadeaux qui ne sont pas vraiment des
cadeaux d'ailleurs battu envoie
quelqu'un dans des conditions exécrables
forcément la personne revient déçu là
c'est vraiment des consignes des
conditions optimales nous perdrons top
kaki offre ça alors là on est sur du
alors j'en sais rien à venir ce mois
directement ses envies d'ailleurs
je crois que c'est jean patrick punta
cana si jean pattes
pis si les avis attention on retrouve l
inquiète avec thau téléphone vous voulez
faire et ça aussi toute la matinée on
peut le faire
faites des tu préfères à cyril tu
préfères south adam versa ou ça et il
nous dit voilà on apprendre un petit peu
à le connaître
non mais c'est vrai alors exactement
elle sa diversité en tout cas ce matin
tellement d'amour tu travailles à 7h15
la banque a mais pourquoi les gays
répondre qu'à partir de 10h alors trois
passes et de respirer j'avais remarqué
les banquiers quand tu leur doit
losail ils t'appellent très tôt quand tu
les appelles pour avoir une info sur ton
compte
impossible d avoir à mamie de ça c'est
incroyable quand je peux dire côté donc
quand tu es dans le rouge fort à la mai
à 7h du matin baloga non mais sur les
rues surtout moi je peux poser une
question dont tu bosses à la bnp 600
âmes et s'avoue probable que les banques
ont dit que je rendrai à des heures où
il ya que les braqueurs qui peut venir
vous voir aller dans une bande là bas
c'est sur deux heures midi 14h 17h c'est
sûr comment es tu vas tu dois aller
chercher les enfants à l'école tu es
mort coin tu peux pas me fait chier riba
je peux pas là je dois aller braquer la
banque jeu pires craintes portant
journée sabine rien est-ce que vous avez
des voiles apparaît donc quand tu
arrives sur ton ordinateur le matin un
autre monsieur hyundai dans le rouge est
ce que tu le vois tout de suite c'est
l'appel tu fais un petit point qui un
petit check in de du client et oui oui
ça dépend du métier que tu fais mais oui
mais oui un as pour ça qu'il m'appelle a
pris de lumières qui s'allument
c'est quand est conseillé c'est ça il
m'appelait un moment mais sans déconner
mais longages avait représenté avec mon
numéro un mais il est resté dans le
rouge il obligé de taper tous les matins
mon grand ouais bon bah voilà je me
serais même quand il n'est pas dans le
rouge à l'appel du pôle par les faits
minute à mon avis c'est non mais plus
maintenant ils m'appellent mois et
m'appeler quand j'ai enroulé maintenant
voilà je suis ni dans le rouge ni dans
le viol et je suis dans une couleur
permet bien entendu rouge carmin et
voilà il m'appelait peu plus m'appelle
plus élevés quand je vais l'appeler
cahier jamais choix jiabao je voulais te
le dire tu voulais me feras tu préférais
oui alors il
oui mais ce que tu préfères recevoir
totally des appels en numéro masqué
ouais mais tout à lire leurs trois de
ces rouleaux ben ouais voilà
ou alors à chaque fois que tu veux
appeler quelqu'un la belle qui répond
non non non je prends les appels masqués
sinon poitiers à une gpec le forfait
coiffera là je paye sans décoller je
paye mille cinq cents lots de téléphone
tous les moins croyants tête c'est pas
la peine non mais remercie mais il était
bon sens tu prêt spécial téléphonie
mobile
je t'embrasse fort ma petite elsa je
chéris chiron voir à sur les réseaux
facebook twitter bien sûr on est l'anti
tous vos messages ça vous fait très
plaisir que cyril sois là ce matin et
c'est jusqu'à 10 heures on va écouter
calme un peu de pop rock électro pascal
juju d'oreca temps les landes où le fils
fait un quart d'heure qu'ils jugent tu
vas chanter frérot je mettais pataugas
un but tu vas chanter soldats quand même
qu'ils ont timberland dans la merde avec
pas mélanger non mais là et il a tout ay
quoi saison dit-il sûr que ça fait pas
tommy non invasive ont-ils dans la mer
ça passe mais j'en ai vus j'ai vu des
gars le faire c'est le l'axé pour le pop
rock électro et dance un instant on se
retrouve avec cyril avec tout le monde
est toujours en direct sur ces 8 sur
virgin radio est évidemment celle virgin
tonique 6h10 heure bon réveil avec cyril
hanouna qui est là bien sûr
moi je suis là j'aime la ville devait
faire les 35 heures ça ne connais pas
les 35 heures je devais faire dans un
but extrêmement précis c'est que j'avais
un but dans la vie c'était pêche ou
martine aubry
je me suis dit alors pour les jeunes qui
nous écoutent et pour les moins jeunes
voilà c'est elle qui aimait les 35
heures payées 35 heures et c'est vrai
que je me suis dit c'est peut-être un
moyen de de la titiller
il ya eu un retour alors il ya eu aucun
retour à d'ailleurs appelé la mairie de
lille tout à l'heure pour lui dire voilà
martine j'ai fait les 35 heures c'est
pour toi elle est gentil on avait fait
l'émission en direct du zénith de lille
exhaler vais faire un petit message est
tout et elle et nous avons envoyé un
beau message
et ben moi aussi parfois j'ai fait une
émission à lille moi aussi un jour très
longtemps m'a envoyé un petit cadeau
sympa mais un petit mot aux habitudes
cette ville est trop petite pour
l'honneur en tout cas ça fait plaisir
qu'ils ciel dans les studios ce matin il
ya plein de patrons qui passe à un
moment il ya manuel valls qui va
oui je suis le patron d'auchan je sais
que je vais dire ça nous a pas porté
chance dans le pays
mais heureusement que tu les fais un
c'est important pour la télévision
alors pari qu'a préparé plein de trucs
toi toi tu es un très sale ça tu ne vas
assure toi c'est pas pour manger c'est
juste un indice qu'est ce que c'est ça
c'est des merguez et des merguez
mais il allait alors je sais
différencier une merguez d'une chipeau
l'audition eh bien on t'a préparé et
pour quelqu'un pour aline qui va jouer
avec nos 39 16 après tout tout au long
de la matinée on va vous régaler en
cadeau comme on le fait chaque jour bien
sûr et le vendredi vous en avez encore
plus besoin vous qui vous réveillez vous
qui partez bosser et aline va jouer tout
simplement un jeu qu'on a dédié c'est le
merguez guèye jingle j'adore
[Musique]
je peux me permettre c'est en rapport
avec nous à consonance maghrébine ne
rien avoir d'accord on annonce à voir
avec le fait que tu es une belle
personne partageant des rigolades et
barbecue dit mairieelle quand il y avait
moins de clichés sur cette radio n'est
pas ce qui nous amène à la station à
l'ena giry comment vas tu déjà ça du
aline tu fais des doux des doublages ou
en dessin animé
aline tu habites ou en lorraine j'adore
la moraine tu sais j'ai vécu j'ai roulé
ma bosse en lorraine j'ai beaucoup pécho
sur la ville de metz lorraine
bah non lorraine willow reynerie moi
j'ai toute ma tête c'est quoi ton avis
quelle classe 4e faut se méfier car
c'est souvent celle on se casse les
dents qui a déjà redoublé là autour de
la table un mois what a redoublé combien
de rire la première mais j'avais un an
d'avancé
finalement je suis arrivé alors et celle
où tu es venu ici pour tapoter je
concevais pas le jeu de la merde c'est
très simple le principe cyril on a pris
des parts des chansons très connues et
on a caché un mot par meriem ben merci
c'est très simple and in situ reconnaît
au moins trois morceaux 3,3 parole tu
auras gagné le grand jeu de la merguez
j'ai le droit de le dire ou pas bien sûr
tu as le relais jean radio ont pris le
temps quand même de créer un panneau le
jeu de l'américain
ah ah quand même le panneau son déconner
on dirait un panneau de promotion dans
un quartier sans déconner en lire et la
merguez à moins 50 de ces partis
première extrait tu dois reconnaître le
mot qui cache et bien sûr un vaste
la merguez
[Musique]
les gars
ray passible on se chauffe c'est la
fatigue oui on se chauffe et qui fait la
voix nicolas bouvard ouais bah bravo
niçois la musicienne les kiwis est ce
que c'est vrai que nicolas bouvard j'ai
travaillé avec lui c'est m le musicien
de l'équipe à chaque fois qu'il fait un
dos il est à fond c'est bien là le gars
quand il a fait l'enregistrement élite
et surtout au dessus du lot il était
persuadé que c'était johnny stade de
france 68 personnes
c'était à metz nico alors tu as trouvé
ma chérie tu retrouves l on y va
attention ça reste simple mais un peu
plus récents il aime bien cette chanson
sur meriem merguez merguez
[Musique]
alors bravo pour limitation ni
commerçants puissent émettre pims en
fait un progrès m qu'est ce qu'ils
mangent des pimms tu veux que je t'aime
elle répondait au nom de merguez
c'est ce que j'entends financer ces
belles la belle ayem est la bonne
réponse attention continue c'est le
grand quizz de la mairie j'adore
petit merguez avec un petit jeu la
dorsale très fort petit mergen même bien
ce qui d'après toi bien sûr bonne
réponse jamais que s'offrait bon merguez
jamais pendant un concert genre hier
francis cabrel d'idron sérieux et tout d
abord il parodie ni avait fait un petit
merguez je t'attends transit soit 8,3
alors il ya combal c'est le meilleur
imitateur francis cabrel c'était limite
à son choix sur soi le meilleur mais
elle te fait rire quand il va zy ont
tellement du jardin bien servi non
cadrée ouais et demie christophe maé on
dirait francis maillet personnalité
aussi si je perds beaucoup je ferai
encore c'est un peu tout le monde en
fait attention des bonnes nouvelles
je fais une merguez ou s'il en faut pas
plus à lyne hallé m'appelle je t'aime
exactement
et tu l'as dit nous allons isolés se
sont ils au royal petite dernière pour
la route c'est parti attention on y va
[Musique]
merguez
si c'est un garçon âgé gourmands oui
mais on peut pas remplacer merguez par
deux mots fléchés pour faire 1 voilà
aujourd'hui on peut pas non plus dans
l'escaladé aux blagues ont bloqué pour
un ipad mini ma petite aline rapidement
est-ce que tu as trouvé 6 1 sur bonnes
réponses et gagner pour toi iphone ipad
mini 2 cjga entre l'envoi dès cet après
midi on est ravi de faire ce cadeau
alain contre un gros buzz wallin salut
ma chérie
bien sûr bien sûr les embrasse fort est
d'environ salle des professeurs 1 en
train de s'en griller une
tout de suite vu qu'il est en train de
battre avec en direct sur virgin sur ces
vidéos ou encore des 35 heures en si tu
penses du petit polo non vraiment lui
l'a complètement le chinois ou le
deuxième trimestre a volé sa vie olemps
le hashtag c'est quoi ces essais un jour
j'y arriverai un jour cyril va réussir
ce défi les 35 heures vous aussi dit
tout ce que vous arriverez à faire un
jour d'aujourd'hui de vous fixer comme
les jets qui vous êtes sûr d'y arriver
un jour on va vous prendre au téléphone
dans un instant de 39,16 bien sûr pour
nous rejoindre comme tous les matins
c'est quoi sa scierie pour écouter dans
un instant let me love you qui est dit
et ce n'est que dieu bénisse
enfin c'est une très belle année les
belles années une très belle année ça
passe tout de suite ça c'est dans un
instant fait un petit peu un petit peu
un point sur tout ça d'accord et puis on
va installer vous sur ces 8 et puis dans
seul instant dont dj snake et let me
love you 39,7 pour nous joindre bougez
pas vous êtes sur virgin radio
[Musique]